[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de cateo pour cette nouvelle édition de
face au chrétiens avec la croix radio
NotreDame et RCF notre invité
aujourd'hui est François BA François
Baou bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes maire de peau vous présidez le
modem vous avez été candidat à
l'élection présidentielle vous avez
également été ministre de l'éducation
nationale vous serez interrogé dans
cette édition de face au chrétiens par
Laurent Boissieux pour la croix bonjour
par Louis dofren pour Radio NotreDame
bonjour et par Véronique de la maison
neuve pour RCF bonjour voilà nous avons
une actualité très chargée des primaires
incertaines à gauche et à droite la
fracture ouverte au sein du Parti
socialiste nous avons une vraie fausse
baisse du chômage nous avons le code du
travail qui va probablement être
retricoté beaucoup de questions et c'est
Laurent Boissieux qui pose la première
question vous avez été candidat à
l'élection présidentielle de 2002 de
2007 de 2012 et vous avez une démarche
assez inédite dans la vie politique là
vous dites que vous soutiendrez un Jupé
s'il l'emporte à la Primare donc vous
êtes prêt à soutir une autre personne en
quoi un Jupé pourrait aussi bien ou
mieux que vous défendre vos convictions
François BA
si l'on regarde la situation politique
française en tout cas comme je la
vois on observe une chose c'est que
depuis des années
c'est un homme de l'appareil des deux
grands partis qui se partagent le
monopole du
pouvoir qui devient président de la
République et ce
faisant bah c'est les deux partis qui
squattent le pouvoir qui instalent leurs
hommes leurs et la démarche d'Alain Jupé
euh fait que c'est
aujourd'hui le mieux placé de ceux qui
veulent qu'on sorte de ce système en
dépit de son passé lui-même ouais mais
passé c'est bien ça fait de l'expérience
il était présent du MP et en 2002 vous
que vous avez précisément refusé de
rejoindre que j'ai refuser de rejoindre
et je m'en félicite et je pense que
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui voient
qu'elle était euh l'erreur fondamentale
de
l'UMP qui consistait à prétendre qu'il y
aurait un parti unique de la droite et
du centre ce qui a empêché qu'il y ait
euh une expression de droite et une
expression du centre et sur l'absence de
droite le Front National a prospéré et
sur l'absence du centre le Parti
socialiste pendant longtemps a fait ses
chou gras et si vous regardez des
régions entières le Sud-Ouest ou la
Bretagne à alors vous constatez que
l'absence du centre a été évidemment une
formidable chance pour pour le PS et
donc je maintiens que j'avais raison
même si c'était seul contre tous de
refuser ce soi-disant parti unique ce
prétendu parti unique et je crois que
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui sont prêts
même s'ils le disent pas publiquement à
à reconnaître que c'était vrai or Alain
Jupé ayant eu ce passé mais ayant eu
d'autres expériences de la vie se
présente aujourd'hui comme plus
indépendant des appareils et il a fait
un choix fondamental que je considère
comme
crucial c'est que il envisage de former
un gouvernement qui dépassera les
frontières des partis ce qui jusqu
jusqu'à où ce comment vous voyez ça on
verra on verra parce que ça dépend de
l'équation du deuxème tour de l'élection
présidentielle
h ça dépend de beaucoup de choses mais
en tout cas le
le
la
perspective de pouvoir former un
gouvernement qui ne soit pas enfermé
dans des frontières partisanes pour moi
c'est quelque chose d'absolument central
il y a beaucoup de si pour que ça arrive
ce que vous attendez il faut que un que
le PS explose deux qu' un JP gagne la
primaire tris qu'un Jup gagne la
présentielle face à Marine Le Pen et
4atre qu'effectivement il fasse le
gouvernement d'un national et bien c'est
c'est en effet quatre hypothèses
sérieuses Louis dofren radio NotreDame
vous verriez Premier ministre d'un Jupé
par exemple non je je j'ai refusé ceux
qui
ont me font l'amitié d'écouter ce que je
dis j'ai refusé d'entrer dans cette
équation pourquoi parce que je considère
que le premier ministre d'un président
nouvellement élu doit appartenir au
parti majoritaire euh ce parce qu'il
faut entraîner euh au moins l'Assemblée
nationale et euh l'équation devant
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui c'est
que il y a peu d'hypothèse que je sois
euh responsable du premier parti de
l'Assemblée nationale euh et donc de ce
point de vue-là il me paraîit il me
paraîtrait pas juste de de laisser
entendre que tel est mon souhait ou mon
rêve euh
parce que
deuxièmement je me refuse à regarder ce
soutien comme un choix égoïste je ne
soutiens pas Alain jupet parce que je
pense que ça sera mieux pour moi je
soutiens alin jupet parce que je pense
que ça sera mieux pour la France mais
quelle place VO
TR je souhaite beaucoup avec
ardeur que si cette élection se produit
si les conditions que vous avez indiqué
sont li cette élection nous permett de
reconstituer en France le centre fort
digne novateur
indépendant
attirant dont le pays a besoin et dont
l'absence marque cruellement la vie
politique mais quelles seraient les
dividendes du soutien que vous
apporteriez à lin Jupé si vous ntes pas
je vi je viens de vous indiquer une des
conséquences mais le mot que vous
utilisez le mot dividend permettez-moi
de vous dire qu'il est pas du tout
adapté à la chose c'est un mot de
placement gen font un placement et ils
attendent un retour sur investissement
ce n'est pas ma vision des choses chaque
fois que j'ai fait des choix dans la vie
et certains étaient pas faciles chaque
fois que j'ai fait ces choix je ne les
ai pas fait pour un intérêt je les ai
fait parce qu'il me semblait
que dans la situation qui était la
mienne avec l'idée que je me faisais euh
de notre pays des temps que nous
traversions il n'aurait pas été digne
que je fasse un autre choix je pose ma
question un peu autrement mais très
brièvement c'est l'ouverture prendrait
quelle forme dans ce cas si jamais il y
a un parti de gouvernement qui est celui
des républicain comment se matérialise
le fait que il y a il y a cette nouvelle
alliance je suis sans doute mal
expqu le plus de la candidature d'Alain
Jupé pour moi c'est qu'il en il ne veut
pas faire un parti un gouvernement ou
une majorité limitée à un parti ni même
à une seule alliance ce qu'il envisage
c'est que il y ait une nouvelle équipe
qui porte une vision plus large de
l'intérêt général que l'intérêt partisan
et vous serez dedans en tout cas je je
serai là pour l'aider Véronique de la
maison d' ver CF qu'est-ce qui vous fait
penser que le pays va vous suivre
justement dans ce centre élargi ça n'a
pas Fran
der
anné pas si mal marché que ça franis si
vous regardez les scores alors vous vous
apercevez et si vous regardez je ne les
lis pas mais enfin je jete un coup d'œil
si vous regardez les dernières enquêtes
d'opinion y compris les dernières
intentions de vote à l'élection
présidentielle alors vous vous apercevez
de quelque chose qui est
extraordinairement frappant il y a un
courant puissant qui a end cette
proposition politique qui se situe ben
ça dépend en 10 15 18 % des voix et
c'est le seul courant de la vie
politique française qui ne soit pas
organisé et
mon intention mon objectif est de
contribuer à l'organisation de ce
courant et et vous vouz pas l'impression
compte 15
% je prends la dernière enquête bon
c'est qu'une enquête d'opinion faite par
un institut sérieux qu'est-ce qu'elle
dit
Hollande Sarkozi sont les deux figures
du PS et de l'UMP
institutionnel ils sont
entre s'agissant de Hollande entre 16 et
18 % s'agissant de Sarkozi autour de 20
entre 18 et 20 % quelque chose comme ça
et le courant qui choisit de voter pour
un de V porter mon nom ce courant là il
est entre 15 et 18 c'estàdire éalité à
peu
[Musique]
prèsut mesurer
tout à peu près au même
niveauter je pense que il est bon de
montrer que les hommes politiques ne
pensent pas toujours à eux quand ils
font des choix je trouve que c'est
intéressant euh de faire mentir le
soupçon de perpétuel égoïme ou
égocentrisme que qui pèse sur la vie
politique française et que les primaires
renforcent chaque jour euh je pense
qu'il est
intéressant de montrer une attitude
désintéressée et qu'on peut en
effet apporter son soutien à d'autres
qu'on n'est pas obligé euh constamment
de penser à soi-même et peut-être ça
fait mentir certain nombre de choses euh
qui ont été dites sur ce sujet Véronique
de la maison ne pardon mais ce que
disent aussi les enquêtes c'est que les
personnes veulent changer de tête aussi
c'est ce qui se dit notamment pour
François Hollande et Nicolas Sarkozy
principalement euh est-ce qu'il y a pas
besoin aussi de de nouvelle
personnalités vous savez c'est très
simple euh si des personnalités
nouvelles veulent s'imposer euh qu'ell
gagnent leur magistrature leur euh place
devant les Français c'est très très
simple le il y a dans la politique
quelque chose de darwinien hein de de la
sélection naturelle des espèces ou des
espèces bon
euh il se trouve que chacun de ceux que
vous citez a gagné parfois
difficilement sa place sur le ring et
bien que les autres en fassent autant il
y a aucune difficulté il suffit de se
présenter de défendre son mon point de
vue de faire passer quelque chose comme
un courant magnétique avec les Français
et vous noterez dans cette dernière
formule que c'est pas le plus simple h
il y a des gens qui peuvent dire
euh ce que qui sont
formidables seulement les Français ne
l'entendent pas de cette oreille et donc
c'est c'est c'est très intéressant de de
suivre ça comme comme un championnat
sportif hein championnat sportif et vous
avez parlé du ring également Laur Bo est
un spécialiste de ce sport pour la croix
on voit très bien en effet la la
aujourd'hui la la convergence c'est plus
d'ailleurs un Jupé vers vos idées que
que l'inverse mais qu'il y a entre vous
le centre et le centre droit mais il y a
aussi un centre gauche qui est un peu
incarné aujourd'hui par Manuel Macron
voir manuel Vals et François Hollande
également pourquoi ne pas soutenir
aujourd'hui ce que veut faire ce centre
gauche cette gauche sociale libérale au
pouvoir et parce que je ne sais pas ce
qu'ils veulent faire les projets de loi
on en parlera très con ib écoutez je
vais vous dire quelque chose de
simple avec beaucoup d'autorité vous
dites le projet de loi il y a pas de
projet de loi il est pas passé au
Conseil minist pas encore été présenté
au Conseil des ministres il y a je le
commenterai quand j'imagine qu'on en
parlera dans la suite de
l'émission Le c'est pour moi une
question depuis très longtemps il m'est
souvent arrivé d'approuver des phrases
du président de la République et même de
voter pour lui sonutour la
présidentielle et lorsque par par
exemple il a dit faut faire une
politique de
l'offre pour l'essentiel je partage ce
jugement après il dit j'ai organisé le
cice ce et à la première seconde vous
vous en souvenez j'ai dit mais c'est une
usine à
gaz on va dépenser beaucoup de milliards
c'est destiné aux entreprises à priori
qui pour pour peu d'efficacité et
notamment pas d'efficacité en direction
des PME ou des petites entreprises qui
sont des créateurs d'emploi très
importants euh bon ça s'est vérifié les
intentions ne sont pas tout il faut que
les actes et les décisions soient au
rendez-vous et pour l'instant à vos yeux
François Baou il ne suivent pas de ce
point de vue-là mais on en parlera
j'imagine dans la suite de l'émission
peutê Tout dernière question François
Baayou vous avez évoqué les primaires
allez-vous vootter au primaires de la
droite et du centre non je ne voterai
pas à titre individuel je ne voterai pas
à ces primaires beaucoup de mes amis
voteront oui et je pense qu'ils feront
le même choix que le mi mais pour moi à
titre personnel voter au primaire ça
aurait une signification extrêmement
précise ça voudrait dire je respecterai
le choix que cette mécanique électorale
entre guillemets aura
prononcé vté or je veux garder ma
liberté parce que il y a des choix que
je suis prêt il y a un choix que je suis
prêt à soutenir et il y a des choix que
je ne suis pas prêt à soutenir dans ce
CASL vousur écoutez nous nous en
parlerons le moment venu mais soyez
assurés que je garderai ma liberté et
que je
l'exercerai très bien nous allons marqué
une première pause dans cette édition de
face au chrétiens je rappelle que notre
invité est François Baayou maire de poau
président du MoDem nous évoquons avec
lui l'actualité politique économique
sociale et internationale à tout de
suite retour sur le plateau de cateo
pour cette édition de face au chrétiens
avec la croix radio NotreDame et RCF
notre invité aujourd'hui François
baayrou président du MoDem maire de peau
il est interrogé par Laurent Boissieux
pour la croix par Louis daofrine pour
Radio notred-dame et par Véronique de la
maison neu pour RCF c'est Louis dafrine
qui pose la première question vous avez
dit que la tribune de Martine auri était
un coup de bistourie donc qui approfondi
la rupture
entre les deux parties de la gauche la
guerre des gauches donc que vous aviez
vu venir depuis longtemps est-ce que
vous estimez que d'abord que c'est bon
signe pour le centre de se retrouver
ainsi dans une position où il aurait pu
prévoir où où il a prévu ce qui s'est
passé à gauche François alors c'est
première affirmation euh moi je trouve
que c'est plutôt mieux euh d'avoir
raison que d'avoir tort de voir venir
les événements euh que euh de ne pas les
voir venir et d'être aveugle en face de
la situation euh le le au fond quand on
regarde l'histoire et sans vouloir
comparer ce qui est incomparable euh je
pense que c'est que c'est euh euh plutôt
mieux d'être
Churchill que d'être Baldwin Baldwin
c'était le premier ministre du temps de
Churchill que tout le monde a oublié qui
avait fait
campagne sur le désarmement de
l'Angleterre alors que Hitler armé
l'Allemagne il a
gagné j'ai même cité dans un de mes
livres un
dialogue absolument fascinant entre ces
deux hommes Baldwin dit oui vous avez
raison mais comme le corps électoral
était pacifiste il fallait que je gagne
les élections donc je suis allé dans son
sens vous
voyzd il dit ça en 36 au moment où tout
bascule donc moi je pense que c'est
plutôt mieux de voir que de ne pas voir
alors évidemment ça suffit pas parce que
il arrive parfois Edgar fort avait
autrefois intitulé Un livre avoir
toujours raison c'est un grand tort
peut-être peut-être
mais cette fracture de la gauche elle
est une donnée majeure du paysage de
l'avenir alors ques sont les conséen au
fond ce qui s'achève là c'est le cycle
qui a été ouvert en 71 par la prise du
pouvoir au Parti socialiste par François
bteran Le Nouveau Parti socialiste dont
il est devenu le premier secrétaire puis
en fait le chef historique et qui était
fondé sur l'accord avec le Parti
communiste pour faire l'union de la
gauche
accord qui disait donnez-moi vos voix je
vos idées c'était c'est à peu près ça
qui s'est passé et donc c'est la fin de
ce cycle tout ça explose il faudra
longtemps à la gauche pour se
reconstruire et on va assister à des
souousbressau qui sont
considérables et qui en effet doivent ou
vont faire naître un nouveau paysage
politique français et pour vous donc
François Baayou la question était
quelles sont les conséquences pour vous
pour le modème pour le centre euh bah
les conséquences sont que on a besoin on
aura besoin
d'un d'une force politique qui au centre
de la vie politique permettra de
reconstruire différemment les majorités
est-ce que c'est l'occasion de créer une
grande coalition social-démocrate comme
il en existe dans d'autres pays
social-démocrate il faut encore
faudrait-il que je fusse
social-démocrate ce qui c'est une
conversation si vous regardez le visage
de Laurent de Boissieux éclairé d'un
sourire c'est une conversation ancienne
je ne suis pas social-démocrate si on
voulait me caractériser
le
l'adjectif est le mien je suis un
démocrate chrétien démocrate chrétien je
suis je je suis un homme du Centre
démocrate chrétien humaniste
d'inspiration spiritualiste si on veut
si on veut dire les choses je pense que
la société elle doit être orientée vers
l'épanouissement de la personne et des
communautés à laquelle ces personnes
appartiennent et ceci est une
philosophie politique qui ne se confond
pas avec la social déémocratie qui peut
travailler avec H mais on peut
travailler avec d'autres familles
politique et deuxièmement c'est une
famille politique dont la marque est que
nous estimons indispensable le
pluralisme dans la vie politique nous
refusons le côté clanique de deux camps
dont l'un celui auquel on appartient à
toujours raison et celui auquel on
nappartient pas a toujours tort et
l'existence du Front national
l'existence de l'extrême gauche la
rupture de la gauche font que ce
pluralisme va devoir s'imposer alors la
vie politique dans un paysage pluraliste
a des règles différentes de la vie
politique que nous avons vécu clan
contre clan et camp contre camp et c'est
heureux parce que le camp contre camp
nous a amené à la catastrophe où nous
sommes c'est parce queon a eu cette vie
politique tronquée
amputée stérile qu'on en est arrivé à la
situation de la France puis-je vous
faire remarquer que nous sommes le seul
pays européen
à avoir vécu avec cette loi desrains et
nous sommes celui qui a échoué le plus
si vous regardeer des choses très
simples le taux de chômage tous les pays
qui nous entourent et qui ont eu notre
histoire après la Libération je mets de
côté l'Espagne par exemple tous ces
pays-là sont à 5 % de chômage nous
sommes à plus de 10 % le double de
chômeurs et donc oui j'estime que ce
système a stérilisé les choses et nous a
entraîné à des choix qui était des choix
absurdes je pense que les 35 heur étit
un choix absurde les 35 heur ça a été un
choix qui n'a pas été fait parce qu'ils
estimaient que c'était mieux pour le
pays ils ont fait ce choix sur un coin
de table parce que c'était mieux pour
gagner les élections et vous voyez à
quel point tout ceci nous a entraîné
dans un dans un gouffre auquel en tout
cas pour ma part je n'ai pas
envie à la fascination duquel je ne
cèderai pas Véronique de la maison 9 RCF
vous av parlé du FN c'est une réalité
une réalité dans les
urnes qu'est-ce que vous dites
provisoirement oui qu'est-ce que vous
dites à à ces électeurs en dehors de on
l'a compris ce centre élargi à ces
chômeurs à ses ouvriers peut-être à des
personnes qui étaient au modem avant et
qui maintenant
mettent le bulletin de de Marine le père
voilàér qu'est-ce que vous leur dites
concrètement s VI VO ça pour les
écteursavantage je leur dis quelque
chose de
simple dans les propositions du Front
national et dans les arrières pensées du
Front national il y a
des propositions qui seront mortel pour
la France lesquels je ne les prends pas
sous l'angle sous l'angle
moral on peut discuter de ça je les
prends sous l'angle simplement de la
réalité qu'elles vont créer
l'affirmation selon laquelle il suffit
de sortir de l'Europe pour régler les
problèmes du pays l'affirmation selon
laquelle ben c'est d'une clarté totale
et vous le verrez dans les mois qui
viennent il suffit de revenir au Fran
cette affirmation là est une affirmation
mortelle suffit de regarder l'Argentine
où se trouve actuellement le le
président de la République c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait aller voir la situation
en Argentine à la suite de l'abandon
enfin du choix de déc
de que la monnaie Argentine décroche de
la parité dans laquelle elle était il y
a eu 1 million et demi d'exilés de gens
qui ont émigré pour sortir de
l'Argentine et aujourd'hui encore on
vient de le voir on n'en est pas sorti
c'est si l'on ne se rend pas compte de
ces choses alors on se rend compte de
rien et puis la deuxième question on
sait bien quelles sont les motivations
du vote c'est des
motivations qui sont en effet des euh
des instincts profonds des sociétés si
vous commencez à regarder les gens du
point de vue de leur origine du point de
vue de leur religion et à faire en sorte
que d'une certaine manière on les montre
du doigt où on laisse entendre qu'on
pourrait les renvoyer que et bien vous
allez au malheur d'un pays
alors cette cette affirmation là je suis
prêt à la soutenir de toutes les
manières du monde ça n'est pas pour moi
une réalité électorale c'est une
question nationale est-ce qu'on veut un
pays qui soit un pays vivant et qui
avance ou est-ce qu'on veut un pays qui
au contraire se se renferme dans ses
obsessions et dans ses névroses il en
mourra et je je pose une question très
simple est-ce que vous pouvez me citer
un seul pays dans l'histoire dans lequel
ce choix politique est entraîné du bien
pour le pays est-ce que vous pouvez m'en
citer un en tout cas ce sont des choix
qui se développent en Hongrie en Pologne
que vous pouvez c'est complètement tent
différent ce qui se passe en Hongrie en
Pologne c'est complètement différent je
rappelle que la Pologne pour l'essentiel
en dehors de la vie interne polonaise
dans lequel la démocratie est pas très
respecter ces temps-ci mais je mets ça
de côté la Pologne est candidate à
l'euro et jamais le gouvernement
polonais actuel n dit nous rompons avec
tout ça donc ce la non mais sur
l'identité la situation est extrêmement
différente François a dit justement y a
quelqu il y a quelques jours que s'il y
avait un parti d'extrême droite qui
prendrait le pouvoir en Europe on
suspendrait il y aurait la possibilité
de suspendre le pays de l'Union
européenne est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça François dans les textes cette
possibilité existe oui est-ce que est-ce
que ça correspond excusez-moi je
refuse que la question de l'identité
soit monopolisée par le Front national
il se trouve que je suis
suis habité par une certaine idée de
l'identité française et pas seulement de
l'identité française mais des identités
à l'intérieur de la
France que je je sais et j'affirme que
l'identité est nécessaire aux
communautés humaines vous ne
pouvez trancher ou décider de là où vous
allez que si vous savez qui vous êtes
vous ne pouvez vivre ensemble et avoir
un débat démocratique que si votre
identité est forte je suis un amoureux
de l'histoire de la France je suis un
amoureux de la langue française j'essaie
de la parler du mieux que je peux je je
j'entre dans les débats culturels on
vient de vivre l'affaire de
l'orthographe ou bien l'affaire de la
réforme du collège j'entre dans ces
débats culturels euh
avec comment dirais-je la volonté et la
passion de défendre quelque chose qui
est tout à fait essentiel
je ne m'estime moins français je ne
m'estime moins français que qui que ce
soit que quiconque au monde et j'affirme
qu'il y a une manière plus
plus rayonnante de vivre l'identité
française que de la bâtir sur un rejet
et donc je récuse l'idée que le Front
national soit le seul défenseur de
l'identité
française je ceci est une question très
importante he parce que les peuples ont
besoin d'identité en particulier dans
l'univers de la mondialisation de la
globalisation comme disent les
anglosaxons ils ont besoin d'identité
simplement il y a d'autres manières
heureusement de vivre cette identité que
cette manière un peu nérotique une
dernière question politique peut-être
sur la droite par la parmi les les les
rares vrai au-delà de de la forme et
vrai proposition divergente entre Al
Jupé et Nicolas Sarkozi
il y a la question du voile à
l'université Nicolas sarquezi veut
interdire le port du voile à
l'université vous avez été confonté à ce
problême là vous é ministre d'éducation
dans les collèges et lycées quelle est
votre position sur le voile à
l'université et bien je vous rappelle
que c'est moi qui ai pris la circulaire
sur le
voile et qui est je suis entré dans la
définition des signes
religieuxostensibles il y a une grande
différence entre ces deux questions
c'est que dans l'une les les jeunes
filles sont dans l'autre les jeunes
filles sont mineures et qu'il y avait
une pression si j'ai pris la circulaire
sur le voile c'est qu'il y avait une
pression sur les jeunes filles pour que
elles se conforme voilà et donc à
l'université c'est complètement
différents ce sont des jeunes filles qui
sont
majeures pour pour toutes enfin pour la
quasi totalité d'entre elles et ça fait
une différence très importante qui
faille les protéger des pression aussi
quand elles ont 20 ans ou 21
ans probablement
cette il faut il faut faire très
attention aussi au sujet
mais selon aucune loi vous ne
pouvez intervenir sur des femmes
majeures comme vous intervenez sur des
enfants mineurs une une dernière
question sur l'évolution de la droite
Bruno Le Maire est apparu sur le marché
de la primaire comment vous lisez cette
candidature François Baayou voulez dire
apparu euh ça veut dire qu'il
NAND déclaré sa candidature bah tout le
monde a le droit de concourir à à cette
primaire je trouve qu'elle prend un tour
un peu inquiétant par la profusion la
prolifération de candidatures mais ça
c'est l'affaire de ce parti et de ceux
qui il participe la mise en examen de
Nicolas Sarkozi c'est quelque chose qui
peut influer sur l'évolution de cet
échiquier politique à
droite moins qu'on ne croit ouis sauf
s'il y a des développements
ultérieurs
mais c'est vrai que
le le trucage des comptes d'une élection
présidentielle pose des questions
démocratiques
fondamentales si c'éit prouvé évidemment
ça veut dire que les élections ne se
jouaient pas à égalité de chances alors
c'est pas la première fois mais c'est la
première fois dans ses proportions c'est
pas la première fois puisqu'on sait que
l'élection de Jacques Chirac et d'édard
Baladur avaient
été comment dirais-je frappé ou marqué
des mêmes dérive sans qu'il y ait
sanctions enfin sanction sans que les
compes de campagne soit mais c'est pire
que ça euh c'est éprouvé ou et le
président du Conseil constitutionnel de
l'époque a dit j'ai sauvé la démocratie
en ne sanctionnant pas ceux qui avaient
ceux qui avaient
truqué leur compte et je trouve ça enfin
à cette époque et comme maintenant j'ai
trouvé ça extraordinairement choquant et
insupportable si vous voulez une vie
démocratique ordinaire vous me permettez
de m'arrêter une seconde à ce
sujet je suis de ceux qui se sont batttu
dans les années 90 pour que la vie
politique française ne devienne pas
comme la vie politique américaine
dépendante de
l'argent la vie politique américaine
pour moi je le dis comme je le pense est
un supportable c'est les banquiers les
pétroliers qui tiennent le pouvoir parce
qu'ils tiennent leur élection et on
dépense on a dépensé lors de la dernière
élection américaine 4 milliards de
dollars sais pas si si on voit ce que ça
veut dire 4 milliards de dollars en
publicité
télévisée et je me suis beaucoup battu
dans les années
90 pour que cette main mise de l'argent
soit interdite en France c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et que notamment les
entreprises h ne puissent pas être
contributrices pour une élection
politique elle l'était auparavant et je
trouvais que c'était complètement
injuste nous avons euh écrit des lois
pour empêcher cette main mise de
l'argent si nous ne respectons pas ces
lois nous ruinons notre vie démocratique
française en tout cas cette idée-là et
pour ma part je pense que ça mérite
qu'on les défende àprement Louis Dofre
donc c'est l'impô qui doit financer la
vie politique c'est l'impô oui il
faudrait que il la
finance avec
justice parce que la situation
d'aujourd'hui j'ai proposer à François
Hollande de revenir là-dessus hein il
l'a pas fait mais la situation
d'aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez une
apparence des lois des financements
publics et une réalité et que la réalité
ce sont les micro partis ce qu'on
appelle les microartis c'est-à-dire des
partis
horsque de la règle générale qui finan
la vie politique des uns et des autres
je trouve que c'est
obscène de même que le fait que la seule
élection majeure du pays ne soit pas
prise en compte dans le financement des
partis l'élection
présidentielle je trouve que c'est une
anomalie incroyable et tout ça au vu et
au-essus de tout le monde et on se
félicite d'avoir des règles et personne
ne les
respecte moi je les respecte mais rendre
le fin nous n'avons pas de microparti
voilà le modem le modem est un parti
pauvre sans doute sans moyens financiers
mais qui n'a pas de dett
et qui ne contrevient pas à la loi et
une de mes fiertés c'est que depuis que
j'ai la responsabilité de cette famille
politique jamais il n'y a eu le moindre
soupçon sur la manière dont elle
fonctionnait donc on peut faire de la
politique sans avoir des moyens
financiers
considérables sans avoir de dette ce qui
est notre cas et ma fois je trouve ça
plutôt
honorable si je peux une
seconde porter un jugement positif sur
Véronique Véronique de la maison 9 vercf
un autre sujet mais qui préoccupe
beaucoup les Français ce sont évidemment
l'année 2015 marqué par les deux
attentats euh est-ce que vous êtes pour
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence qu'a
décidé François Hollande et plus
largement est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement et le président ont bien
géré euh cette période en tout cas faut
versaill question en tout cas je
soutiendrai euh la demande de moyens
pour que
euh on puisse lutter efficacement contre
ces
horreurs et le le et je ne partage pas
les inquiétudes qui sont ici ou là
exprimé je pense que le problème
principal de la France en tout cas je
n'ai remarqué aucune atteinte au liberté
depuis que l'état d'urgence existe je
sais pas vous non mais c'est c'est
effectivement ce que disent les moi en
tout cas personne contre dans à la fois
dans ma vie personnelle et dans mes
fonctions je n'ai noté aucune espèce
d'atteinte aux liberté il y a eu un
débat dans ma ville parce que la
municipalité précédente refusait les
caméras de vidéosurveillance et de vidéo
protection j'ai évidemment
installé un réseau de vidéo protection
j'ai pas remarqué qu'il eu la moindre
atteinte aux libertés mais ça nous a
permis de résoudre des affaires
judiciaires et malheureusement vous
savez qu'à il y a eu des drames
absolument épouvantables sur sur ce
sujet donc je suis très cont de l'avoir
fait moi je ne vois pas de risque pour
les libertés et il y a une précaution
pour que aucun risque pour les libertés
ne puisse être pris c'est que les
décisions soient prises sous le contrôle
d'un juge je judiciaire administratif
judiciaire monsieur est-ce qu'il y a eu
un manquement entre le premier attentat
Charlie et et le deuxième dans la façon
de de de gérer est-ce qu'on a laissé
peut-être passer certaines personne et
peut-être on aurait pu faire mieux c'est
pas simple moi je crédite les
responsables publics sous tous les
gouvernements de faire tout ce qu'ils
peuvent dans ce sens-là je vais pas
donner des leçons comme ça de j'ai pas
les éléments qui me permettraient de le
faire pour moi en tout cas j'imagine que
ils font tout ce qu'ils peuvent est-ce
qu'on aurait pu faire mieux peut-être
mais c'est protéiforme ça a des milliers
de visages les menaces je trouve que on
en déjoue un certain nombre et je trouve
que tous les efforts qui sont faits vont
plutôt dans le bon sens c'est que tous
les moyens qui doivent être apportés
méritent d'être soutenus très bien
François Baou nous avons encore beaucoup
de questions à vous poser nous avons
marqué une nouvelle pause dans cette
édition de face au chrétiens vous restez
avec nous à tout de
suite retour sur le plateau de cateo
pour cette édition de face au chrétien
avec la croix radio NotreDame RCF notre
invité François Baayou maire de peau
président du MoDem il est interrogé par
Laurent Boissieux pour la croix Louis
dofren pour Radio notred-ame et
Véronique de la maison neu pour RCF
c'est Véronique qui ouvre le feu pour
cette dernière partie on parle beaucoup
en ce moment de la réforme du Code du
travail euh est-ce qu'elle était utile
pour vous est-ce que c'est la solution
euh est ça bouge beaucoup he utile
encore faudrait-il que nous sachions ce
qui est dans le texte pour moi pour
l'instant je ne le sais pas j'ai des
indications mais je ne le sais pas euh
est-ce qu'elle était utile bah là il
faut qu'on ait un jugement qui soit un
jugement un peu
construit il y a des orientations qui
sont
utiles et l'orientation qui est la plus
utile pour moi celle qui permet le plus
de dégeler la création d'emploi c'est
toute décision qui permettra au créateur
d'emploi de penser que si jamais ils
étaient obligés d'interrompre le contrat
de travail ça ne ser pas épouvantable du
point de vue de la justice de du point
de vue financier et cetera le je ce que
je vois dans ma
ville les gens me disent François tu
veux qu'on embauche très bien et comment
ça qu'est-ce qui se passe si ça se passe
mal tu veux qu'on embauche
permets-nous de sortir de cette embauche
si ça va mal sans avoir des choses
compliqu les syndicats contre vous qui
vont vous dire c'est
ce vous êtes vous êtes vous êtes
démocrate chrétien je pense vous
avezintention à l'humain un salarié qui
arrive avec un contrat qui peut être
vite cassé par son employeur forcément
n'arrivera pas à avoir un prêt pour
acheter un
logement nous en avons déjà parlé
ensemble ceci est une autre question je
pense qu'il doit y avoir une
possibilité par exemple de de trouver
des garanties de prêt qui ne soient pas
uniquement lié au contrat de travail euh
mais pour moi en tout cas si vous
regardez ce que mattho Renzi a fait en
Italie et qui a dégelé des centaines de
milliers d'emplois alors vous y
retrouverez une proposition que je crois
je faisais depuis 10 ans qui était un
CDI à droit progressif c'est-à-dire que
plus vous restez longtemps dans l'emploi
plus vous avez de droit euh et c'est
d'une certaine manière une assurance
donnée aux créateurs d'emploi plus plus
le le CDI peut être facilement rompu
moins longtemps vous resterez dans
l'emploi et bien je ne crois pas du tout
ça parce que les CDI euh ils sont rompus
tous les jours et ça va devant les
prudhommes et ça prend des mois et des
mois et les indemnités on les on les
connaît très bien il suffirait de les
prévoir à l'avance et donc de ce point
de vue là en tout cas je je trouve que
c'est utile donc ça créera des emplois
pour est-ce oui si c'est mise en place
de manière ser
si on arrive à à adopter ce genre de
chose il aurait fallu une préparation
différente mais bon il y a d'autres
mesures que je n'approuve pas par
exemple je n'approuve pas le fait que on
veuille que les heures supplémentaires
soient moins payées qu'elles ne le sont
aujourd'hui moi je pense que pour le
salarié une heure supplémentaire doit
rapporter doit permettre d'avoir un
pouvoir d'achat plus important et donc
la prime liée à l'UR supplémentaire n'a
pas à être baissée autre chose et de
savoir quelles sont les conséquences
pour l'entreprise et comme vous savez je
propose depuis longtemps que cette prime
liée à l'URE supplémentaire on puisse
alléger les charges sociales du même
montant ça coûterait pas plus cher pour
l'entreprise mais ça rapporterait
beaucoup plus au salariés et donc je ne
suis pas sur toutes les décisions de la
loi présenté et c'est pourquoi les
débats sont intéressants et importants
il demeure qu'au fond du fond de cette
affaire il y a deux conceptions euh de
euh du droit social de la politique
tiens 3è remarque tout le monde dit euh
on va simplifier le droit du travail
vous vous souvenez que j'avais présenté
dans une grande émission les 2 kilos du
droit du travail et même des
journalistes vos confrères m'ont dit
mais c'est pas vrai c'était euh c'est
pas fondé euh vous n'avez pas présenté
les textes c'était la jurisprudence j'ai
présenté les textes en effet il y a 2000
pages et même aujourd'hui il doit y en
avoir un peu plus parce que c'était une
édition qui a déjà presque 2 ans est-ce
qu'on allège on allège rien du tout on
augmente encore en introduisant le texte
de Robert Badinter comme un préambule au
droit du travail donc j'ai à la fois la
certitude que c'est un sujet très
important qu'il aurait fallu traiter
très très tôt bon le traite aujourd'hui
ça mérite un débat qui est un débat
sérieux mais un certain nombre des
mesures proposées ne me vont pas voilà
l'équilibre h wiofen radio NotreDame
donc vous estimez que la France devrait
suivre par exemple ce qu' a fait Cameron
en Angleterre ou est-ce que ça serait un
qu'est-ce que fait Cameron en Angleterre
ce que fait Cameron en Angleterre à mon
avis est un grand risque pour lui un
grand risque pour la Bretagne et un
grand risque pour l'Europe là vous
parlez du brexit on est oui he oui non
je parle de la sa façon dont il veut
faire revenir la société civile par
rapport à un étatisme jugé excessif ou
est-ce que c'est ça ça vous correspond
euh ce que dit Bruno Le Maire un peu
aujourd'hui euh nous avions il y a des
années avec père fit pour moi-même un
peu plus tard défendu l'idée d'une
société de
confiance c'est-à-dire que euh les
acteurs de la société sont reconnus
comme légitimes les contrôles sont pas à
priori il sont à postériori euh on on
fait confiance à leur inventivité ça
c'est une orientation nécessaire alors
justement j'ai j'ai une petite question
pour l'ancien ministre de l'Éducation
quel est votre puisque vous dites qu' y
a une société de l'inventivité de la la
confiance quel est votre regard sur le
le hors contrat aujourd'hui dans les
initiatives qui sont prises les écoles
les écoles hors contrat ne se trouver ni
dans le système de l'éducation nationale
ni dans celui de l'enseignement sous
contrat est-ce que vous regardez ça
comme une anomalie est-ce qu' une forme
d'indentivité de liberté qu'il faut
encourager je vais vous dire c'est une
fatalité si vous vous avez un système
éducatif sous l'autorité de l'éducation
nationale qui ne correspond pas aux
demandes des parents alors vous allez
voir se développer le hors contrat
c'est-à-dire des gens qui auront les
moyens d'assurer à leurs enfants
l'éducation dont il
pensent que le système public ou privé
sous contrat ne peut pas assurer la
charge qu'on leur qu'on leur transmet
pas ce qu'il faut qu'on ne leur apprend
pas c'est ce qu'il disent ce qu'ils
attendent qu'on ne le le qu'il n'y a pas
le le climat qu'ils attendent plus
l'éducation
nationale et l'enseignement privé qui
est sous le sous l'autorité de
l'éducation nationale euh
déviront de leur mission plus vous
verrez se développer ce type
d'enseignement et c'est pourquoi moi je
suis très comme vous savez très très
triste et très fâché de la politique qui
est conduite au sein de l'éducation
nationale dont je considère qu'elle va à
l'encontre de ce que le pays une grande
partie de la société une grande partie
des parents et l'immense majorité des
enseignants attendent on est en train de
de prendre des décisions notamment avec
la réforme du collège qui sont des
décisions qui qui sont une atteinte
profonde euh quelque chose qui blesse
les enseignants ils essaient de le dire
de toutes les manières on les sanction
les enseignants qui n'ont pas suivi la
formation à la réforme du collège on les
sanctionne et c'est et c'est on peut pas
imaginer ce qu'est
aujourd'hui et je le dis
avec très grande affection on peut pas
imaginer ce qu'est aujourd'hui la chute
de morale au sein de l'éducation
nationale peut pas imaginer le sentiment
de
d'incompréhension d'être pas respecté
euh parce qu'on porte atteinte à ce que
les enseignants ont de plus précieux je
vais vous dire il y a les enseignants de
gauche les enseignants du centre les
enseignants de droite ils ont des choses
précieuses en commun ils croient à la
culture ils croi à la compétence il
croit aux concours nationaux il croit
que que que ce qu'on apprend c'est
précieux il croit que euh on n'est pas
là pour faire de l'occupationnel pour
les élèves mais euh tout en les
respectant en les entraînant en riant
avec eux en étant ému avec eux on est là
pour leur apprendre quelque chose euh et
le ministère leur dit constamment le
contraire et ils en souffrent énormément
est-ce que vous vous feriez quelque
chose pour leur contrat je pose juste
cette
questionlsil faut faire pour le contract
ça veut dire je sais rien est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a de nouvell contract sa
définition c'est qu'il a choisi d'être
hors éducation nationale ben je c'est
c'est la définition Mme
d'accord mais mais vous voyez ce que ça
veut dire he ça veut dire quelque chose
d'extrêmement précis ça veut dire que
ceux qui ont les moyens peuvent avoir
l'éducation qu'ils veulent et que les
autres on leur
refuse par exemple le fait que on
supprime dans l'éducation les humanités
classiques ou des orientations
linguistiques euh c'est terrible parce
que je connais bien des familles dans
lesquelles oui on fera ce qu'il faut
pour que les enfants reçoivent
découvrent des chances extraordinaires
de maîtriser la pensée la langue
l'histoire et cetera les autres non je
trouve que cette que ce déclassement là
que cette que cette discrimination là
est honteuse pour la France autrepe dire
quelque chose
enc VI mais j'ai presque
fini on écrit sur nos monuments publics
et tout le monde répète à
l'envie liberté égalité
fraternité égalité liberté et fraternité
le plus sensible c'est à l'école c'est
là que ça se réalise très souvent dans
la vie c'est des injonctions morales là
ça se ré là c'est la vérité je
je j'ai été au lycée à partir de la 6e
dans un petit lycée au pied des Pyrénées
qui s'app le lycée de naï et là nous les
enfants de paysans tout petits paysans
les enfants d'ouvriers les enfants de
commerçant on a appris le latin et le
grec avec des des esprits éminents et
l'histoire avec des esprits éminentsou
et et ça a sauvé notre vie aujourd'hui
vous voyez bien ce qui se passe c'est
que ça va plus être possible une toute
dernière question en un seul mot de Laur
boiss r plus intégré jusqu démocratie
européenne c'est jusqu'au fédéralisme
parce que cette n'est pas morte qu'on va
pas faire une Europe à la carte sur
l'exemple de ce que veut faire David
Cameron euh je n'aime je suis pas à
l'aise avec le mot fédéralisme oui parce
que il dit en français des choses qui
sont le contraire c'est la démocratie
européenne fédéralisme
réalité le fédéralisme pour un Français
ça veut dire concentration des pouvoirs
à Bruxelles alors que le fédéralisme la
philosophie fédéraliste c'est l'inverse
c'est tout ce qui peut être fait au
niveau votre Europe est-elle morte face
à une Europe tel que David Cameron la
voit à la carte ou je choisis t telle
politique alors disons deux choses la
première c'est que les décisions qui ont
été prises la manière dont le débat a
été organisé sont un très mauvais signal
pour
l'Europe que le gouvernement français
n'a pas fait ce qu'il devait faire il
n'a pas défendu une position ferme il
n'a pas tracé une route auquel les
autres dirigeants européens auraient pu
se référer et deuxièmement est-ce que
l'Europe que peut
continuer comme elle est non parce que
précisément il n'y a aucun élément de
démocratie c'est-à-dire d'accès des
citoyens à la décision européenne et
donc on fait de ce point de vue-là
doublement fausse route on aurait dû
résister à Cameron en disant mais
Monsieur le Premier Ministre si vous
voulez partir vous partez si vous voulez
rester on discute de la réforme
nécessaire de l'Europe on a fait le
contraire et en tout cas on peut pas en
rester dans l'enlisement où on se
trouveès ce sera votre dernier mot
François Baayou merci d'avoir accepté
cette invitation on a encore beaucoup de
questions à vous poser mais vous
reviendrez nous voir la semaine
prochaine l'invité de face au chrétien
sera pouria Amir Chah député socialiste
des Français de l'étranger et très très
opposé à la politique actuelle du
gouvernement merci à vous tous de votre
fidélité à la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]